coming up on 6 25 now on your friday
morning something that's been driving
raiders fans crazy well you know parking
for those home games at allegiance
stadium we got one coming up monday now
the raiders website has some great
information
including a detailed map that pinpoints
the 15 entry gates between russell road
and hacienda the east and west side
drop-off locations the rideshare
drop-off and pickup area north of the
stadium as well as the taxi area at
procyon and diablo to the west of
allegiant
then there are the numerous parking lots
several surrounding allegiant with
others as far away as trop and valley
view
as for which to choose from the website
has links to spot hero and parking.com
where you can find and pay for your spot
and that much cheaper no driving option
the regional transportation commission's
game day express and you don't have to
try to remember all of that we've got
links to those websites in the online
version of this story go to eight news
now dot com click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone and if there
is something driving me crazy you can
always email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com